a suspected stalker arrested at Kendall  Jenner's house LAPD confirmed to ETA  trespassing call came in at 945pm Sunday  and while it's unclear whether the call  actually came from Kendall police  arrested a 25 year old male on suspicion  or stalking outside her hollywood hills  home the suspect was booked and bail was  set at a hundred and eighty thousand  dollars earlier that night Kendall was  spotted getting dinner with friend Tyler  the Creator at the grove in los angeles  i like to be pretty chill i mean anytime  I can get to hang out with my friends I  do that the scary encounter at her home  is a far cry from her time in Turks and  Caicos last week Kendall help celebrate  her sister Kylie's 19th birthday at the  exclusive pearls of Long Bay estate the  20 year old appeared to enjoy her little  getaway bringing along her BFF hailey  Baldwin  you